this is the Sun and this is a neutron
star but don't let its size fool you
neutron stars are massive gravitational
monsters and orbiting one wouldn't end
up well for our planet but what if we
took just a spoonful of it and
transported it to earth such a tiny
amount of a neutron star couldn't
possibly destroy us all or could it this
is what if and here's what would happen
if a spoonful of neutron star appeared
on earth when a star about four times
the size of our Sun explodes in a
supernova it propels its outer layers
into space leaving only a dense
collapsing core behind a neutron star
neutron stars are very very dense they
could have the diameter of a small city
but their mass would be 1.4 times the
mass of our Sun of course no neutron
star will ever appear on our planet by
itself first you'll have to grab a
spoonful of it and bring it back to
earth you'll find the nearest neutron
star nicknamed Calvera 617 light-years
away from Earth if you jumped in the
fastest spaceship we've ever built it
would still take you eleven million
years to travel to Calvera I'll have to
fast forward here and meet you in the
neutron stars neighborhood you'd be
trying to get your spacecraft through a
magnetic field that's tens of millions
of times stronger than Earth's your
ship's computers would be useless if
they had any ferromagnetic materials
like iron nickel or cobalt in them you
wouldn't want any of those materials
anywhere in your craft
you'd have to dodge the electromagnetic
radiation beam shooting from the star
faster than you can blink and then when
you finally managed to get to the
surface of caldera you'd be immediately
vaporized due to the temperatures being
around 1 million degrees Celsius
Fahrenheit at this point would it even
matter any part of your craft that
wasn't vaporized would be crushed by the
Stars intense gravity but let's not end
your story right there instead let's
equip you with a super suit that could
withstand the insanely hot temperatures
and the extremely high pressure of a
neutron star and here you have it a
spoonful of Calvera loaded on your ship
now what if you tried to scoop the Sun
with a teaspoon you'd only get about 2
kilograms of it the same amount of a
neutron star would weigh anywhere from 1
billion to 6 billion tons you wouldn't
be able to lift that spoon in the first
place and that's not even the worst part
because the gravity of a neutron star is
so intense it fuses protons and
electrons together only neutrons are
left in that stellar core when they
aren't buried down inside a star
neutrons don't last too long after 10
minutes the scoop of a neutron star
would break down into protons and
neutrons and release as much energy as
the Sun produces in 2 or 3 seconds good
thing you didn't have enough time to
bring that stuff back to earth
leave neutron stars where they belong
far far away from us and if one ever
comes a little too close to earth jump
on a spaceship and escape to another
planet outside the solar system but that
would be a story for another what if
[Music]
you